the senate has voted not to convict
donald trump
in his impeachment trial making him
the most acquitted president in american
history
nobody ain't nobody more innocent
than donald trump uh great news for him
i think
very good news for the republican party
but the trial is not over
actually the real trial the real trial
for the future of the gop
is just about to begin i'm michael
knowles the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday
is from valor who says liberals say
we want strong and powerful women also
liberals
this woman has an opinion we don't like
fire her i think this refers to
gina carano my favorite new colleague
here at the daily wire
gina carano gets canned by disney plus
just for being a conservative they made
up some stuff about
how she said something that was
offensive she didn't she didn't say
anything that was offensive
uh she is just conservative and they
don't like that so disney fired her
well the libs loss is our gain uh of
course
the left doesn't want to hear from women
or any other group of people
uh unless they're willing to toe the
left wing line
and when they don't they think they can
destroy their careers and now we are
pushing back against that
too bad for them you know
all of this is really coming up in
decisions of hiring and firing that's
where the cancel culture really shows up
when you want to find the best quality
candidate for your business you've got
to check out
zip recruiter finding great candidates
to hire can be very
difficult and then the the other thing
that a lot of businesses don't
realize or they realize it only too late
is that time is money right
so if you use one of these services and
you basically just throw spaghetti at
the wall and say oh i hope someone sees
my job posting
you're gonna be wasting a lot of time
and a lot of precious resources uh don't
do that use zip recruiter they're the
best in the game
they will go out they will send out your
listing to
over 100 of the top job sites with one
click then
zip recruiters matching technology will
find people with the right skills and
experience for your job
and actively invite them to apply you'll
get qualified candidates
fast do not do not use this like
you know you sort of just put everything
out there for the world and hope it
works out
use this excellent technology to help
you find
a candidate zip recruiter so effective
that four out of five employers who post
once a recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day
right now
you can try zip recruiter for free can
you believe that's a price we all can
afford
at ziprecruiter.com knowles
ziprecruiter.com
k-n-w-l-e-s zip recruiter.com
knowles go to zip recruiter the smartest
way to hire
actually my uh doppelganger
just recently lost his job we'll get to
that in just a little bit
the big news of the day donald trump
acquitted in the senate impeachment
trial
there have been many questions is this
even a legitimate impeachment trial can
you impeach an
ex-president well i guess he was
impeached when he was a president
then the trial was of this private
citizen now in florida this former
president
can't remove him from office the chief
justice is not presiding
as the constitution demands but they
thought they could prevent him from
running office for office again in the
future
maybe in 2024 none of that matters
anymore
yes donald trump got acquitted we always
knew he was going to get acquitted
though the trump legal team was a little
bit shaky in their early arguments the
democrat house impeachment managers were
doing a very good job
finally in the last day of their
presentation the trump lawyers
brought the goods everything the
democrats had been setting them up for
the trump lawyers let loose the house
manager spoke about rhetoric
about a constant drum beat of heated
language
well as i'm sure everyone ex watching
expected
we need to show you some of their own
words
i i just don't even know why there
aren't uprisings all over the country
maybe there will be
there needs to be unrest in the streets
for as long as there's unrest in our
lives
you gotta be ready to throw a punch you
have to be ready to throw a punch
donald trump i think you need to go back
and punch him in the face
that i thought he should have punched
him in the face feel like punching him
i'd like to take him behind the gym if i
were in high school
we were in high school i'd take him
behind the gym and beat the hell out of
him no i wish you were in high school i
could take him behind the gym
i will go and take trump out tonight
take him out now when was the last time
an actor assassinated a president
they're still going to have to go out
and put a bullet in donald trump show me
where it says that protests are supposed
to be polite
and peaceful
i have thought an awful lot about
blowing up the white house
please get up in the face of some
congress people
oh that doesn't sound so great because
what the democrats have been telling us
for this entire trial
is that if you call
for aggressive political action
if you use terms like fight you know
every politician uses fight but trump he
said you gotta go fight
he's inciting an insurrection he is a
traitor to his country
he needs to be impeached and prevented
from running for office
but then you listen to the democrats and
they all said not just the same thing
they said things that were a lot
worse lindsey graham made a great point
after the
trial where he said if if we're going to
impeach trump don't forget
we did impeach trump he was impeached
twice
acquitted both times but he was
impeached twice if we're going to do
that
we've got to impeach kamala harris we've
opened pandora's box
to future presidents and if you use this
model i don't know how
kamala harris doesn't get impeached if
the republicans take over the house
because she actually bailed out rioters
and one of the writers went back to the
streets and broke somebody's head open
so we've opened pandora's box here and
i'm sad for the country
i agree i think it is sad for the
country it's sad for the country that
kamala harris is vice president that
somebody like her
would become a vice president obviously
nobody likes her that's why she was one
of the first people adding she was the
first person out of the presidential
race but she made it in sort of through
the back door and now she's the vice
president
heartbeat away from the oval office with
the oldest president ever
she was not merely using harsh political
rhetoric she was openly encouraging
political violence and then bailing out
the violent rioters and sending them
back to commit more violence on the
streets
and there's no constitutional question
as to whether or not she can be
impeached
she's not a former official i i thought
that the republican held senate if they
had any
spine whatsoever ought to have censured
her
and and even removed her from office
when she was still a senator before she
assumed the role of vice president mitch
mcconnell wasn't going to do that
actually he's uh he's disappointed a lot
of republicans in the past few days
which we'll get to in a second
but now kamala harris is the sitting
vice president no question you can
impeach her
and you should by the standards that the
democrats have imposed
do i think that harsh political rhetoric
ought to be sufficient for an
impeachment no i wish that were not the
case but i'm also unwilling to
unilaterally disarm
if the left is going to to force this
kind of politics
on all of us that that question is not
in dispute whether or not we can impeach
kamala now joe biden licking his wounds
here because they lost the democrats
just completely lost
again is he's saying that okay yeah
we you know we lost the impeachment
trial but
but the substance of the issue is not in
dispute
i guess that's true in the sense that he
was he was acquitted by
by the senate so it's not in dispute
yeah you're right he isn't guilty of the
thing that the house democrats accused
him of
if it is in dispute in any way uh you
know it might be because democrats are
still trying to make some
some farcical argument but surely it's
not the case that the charge is not in
dispute in the favor
of uh joe biden and the democrats
it's done the trump part of it is over
but now
the question is where do we go from here
because the democrats are going to keep
licking their wounds here i mean they
were already setting this up
earlier they said look there's no way
we're going to get a fair trial here
this is all going to be run horribly
eric swalwell former future president
eric swalwell
who is me and you and everybody else
according to his campaign
he said that god could have been called
as a witness republicans still wouldn't
have listened
the choice was well do we chase those
people
not knowing what they're going to say to
the courts for years
or do we go forward with a powerful
thundering case that we have
and also knowing that mitch mcconnell
was already telling us that
he believed the challenge was a
jurisdictional one so we could have
called god herself
and the republicans weren't going to be
willing to convict so we're proud of the
case we put forward
[Music]
god herself did you hear that wow zing
oh eric so edgy
by the way whatever happened to
respecting people's preferred pronouns
god has been very clear about his
preferred pronouns
he goes by father he is incarnate
in jesus christ the second person of the
trinity the third person of the trinity
is the bond of love between the father
and the son
goes by he and him throughout the entire
bible
now eric swalwell oh he's going to be
very insistent that we call caitlyn
jenner she
but god goes by herself now this is not
just
a glib comment i mean i suppose for
eric's well well it is a glib comment
but you can read something a little bit
deeper here
which is that what the left is seeking
to do ultimately
is to upend the whole society this is a
simple point it almost doesn't even need
to be said
but i i i want to highlight it now
because we're being told republicans are
upending the constitutional order
they have no respect for democracy in
our political traditions
give me a break give me the only people
in this country who are trying in any
way or desire in any way to uphold our
political traditions
are the republicans are the
conservatives the left hates this stuff
they're trying to upend our entire
language they're trying to upend
our social institutions they're trying
to upend the
way the government is run they're trying
to upend even the family the bedrock
political institution
and they're trying to upend our
religious principle too not just the
politics not just the culture but even
the religion
to invert the character and identity of
god
eric swalwell could not tell you that's
what he's doing he can't tell you a
whole lot but that is what he's doing
and that is the implication of so much
of what these
democrats and the left broadly are up to
so you've got this party-line vote
basically you've got
in the house you've got a few squishes
notably liz cheney
who vote with the democrats to impeach
but overwhelmingly the republicans vote
against impeachment
and then you get to the senate for the
trial and the republicans overwhelmingly
vote
not to convict because donald trump
did not do just the simple crime that
they're accusing of him of incitement of
an insurrection
he doesn't even come close to meeting
the legal standard for that
so it's even even if you're not talking
about the jurisdictional question
is it a real trial does the senate have
the right to do this blah blah blah he
just
didn't commit the crime he doesn't meet
the legal standard but
there were a handful of republicans who
voted to convict him
and these guys are losers they are
total losers i don't i mention this
on friday and you know i i i try not to
be trumpian in my rhetoric you know and
too blunt and insulting all the time
but sometimes you just got to call a
spade a spade and these guys
romney collins sas toomey
burr murkowski cassidy they're
just losers who might talk a good game
when they're
in the room with republican donors and
maybe even when they're at the vfw hall
or somewhere else on the campaign trail
they'll talk a good game they'll talk
about how they want to preserve the
country
and you know they're they're going to
uphold conservative principles
and then the moment comes where real map
really matters there's the heat of the
fight
things are really on the line what do
they do they cave
because they might have a lot of
political virtues i think they do
sas is obviously a very intelligent guy
you've got phd you're right
romney is pretty intelligent founded
bain capital
but they lack one virtue that's really
really important and that's courage
they're cowards now you might say no
they're not coward they're courageous
they're standing up to their party
no they're sucking up they're licking
the boots of the liberal establishment
because that's their real party and
their job is to exist as court jester
conservatives
to do a little soft shoe and and justify
you know the the ruling regime but
they're not really fighting
for for conservative principles it's
cowardly
and it's deceitful and it goes all the
way up to leadership
you know it's hard to sleep well at
night in troubled political times such
as these
one way to sleep well at night of course
would be to sleep on bowling branch
sheets this is one of the few ways
that you can be guaranteed to sleep well
at night i have a newborn baby so i'm
not
merely kept up by the political problems
ravaging the country
but also my little terror my sweet
little bundle of joy
night terror uh little june little
junior knowles uh
screams at me all night long it's
important these days
it's important for me with my lovely new
son whom i love the apple of my eye
also a little bit of a terror at night
it's very important to get all the sleep
you can
bowl and branch sheets are the best
they're the best in the business
i've been fortunate on a few occasions
where if i'm traveling and you know i'm
doing
i'm there for work or something i get to
stay in a nice hotel not the like super
eight that i that i would pay for if it
were up to me
uh when you stay in the nice hotel first
thing you notice the quality of the
sheets the quality of the bedding
especially in my single days i would
only ever buy the cheapest it was like
sandpaper on my bed
do not cheap out you're going to spend a
lot of time on your bed sleeping make
sure
it is on the greatest quality
sheets a bullet branch uses only 100
sustainable raw materials
they are the first fair trade certified
manufacturer of linen you can feel as
good about your bowling brand sheets as
they feel against your skin
they're just made to a higher standard
really thoughtful attention to every
detail experience the best sheets that
you've ever felt at bowl and branch dot
com get 15 off your first set of sheets
when you use promo code michael at
checkout that is
b-o-l-l and branch dot com promo code
michael
m-i-c-h-a-e-l you will thank me every
time you get into your bed
the question of this impeachment trial
is not whether donald trump incited an
insurrection and does he meet the legal
standard and is it juris
does the senate have jurisdiction and
what is the constitution it's not that's
not the question of the trial
the question of the trial is what's the
future of the gop
what's the question of the conservative
movement what is the conservative
movement
traditionally you know in recent history
we trace the kind of modern conservative
movement to the end of world war ii
to people like william f buckley jr to
people like russell kirk
to the founding of national review to
the publication of god in many yale
to the goldwater movement to a degree to
the reagan movement
to some of the questions that come up
after the reagan movement you know do we
go with bush do we go with buchanan
what does the future look like then you
get another bush and and we never really
resolved what
you know the conservative movement made
sense when we had a common enemy in the
soviet union
because you could you were able to bring
together the libertarians and the
traditionalists and the foreign policy
hawks
because they all hated the the evil
soviet union for different reasons but
they all hated them then the soviet
union goes away
you say well okay what are these three
groups they don't really have that much
in common
so what holds them together and then
we're kind of kind of fighting over what
is the future of the conservative
movement
and so you've got generally speaking the
more right-wing people the more
traditional conservative people
generally speaking they liked trump
trump was was speaking
closer to their language he was giving
them more of their priorities he was
taking their concerns seriously
and the more liberal wing of the
republican party more liberal wing of
the conservative movement you saw
kind of hate trump and they were you
know the dogged never trumpers got you
know
you think guys like mitt romney would be
a good example of this
and the most insufferable among them
were people like the lincoln project
who they said they're the principled
conservatives we'll get to just how
principled they are in
in a moment but this goes up even to gop
leadership guys like mitch mcconnell
what do we think about mitch mcconnell
do we think mitch mcconnell is some
conviction conservative you know he's a
rock-ribbed right-winger
no i never thought that
during during the tea party
conservatives hated mitch mcconnell
they felt he was weak didn't have a
spine he was a squish
then during the 2016 campaign when he
held up
the filling of antonin scalia's vacated
supreme court seat all of a sudden he
seemed to grow his spine
he was pretty good especially on the
judges he was really good under trump
say oh wow cocaine mitch man that guy is
he's doing it he is
now why was he doing it i think he cared
about the judges and i think he's a
great
wielder of the levers of power he's a
great institutional kind of man
and he cares about certain priorities
but but not all of them
so mcconnell votes not to convict trump
in the trial but he savaged trump
in a speech that he gave on the effect
of of the president
the house accused the former president
of quote incitement
that is a specific term from the
criminal law
let me just put that aside for a moment
and reiterate something
i said weeks ago
there's no question none
that president trump is practically
and morally responsible
for provoking the events of the day
no question about it
the people who stormed this building
believed they were acting on the wishes
and instructions of their president
and having that belief was a
foreseeable consequence
of the growing crescendo of false
statements
conspiracy theories and reckless
hyperbole
now as always mitch mcconnell is having
it both ways right because he votes
not to convict he votes to acquit
so that's why i don't want to go too
hard after mcconnell here
because he you know push comes to shove
he voted the right way
but then at the same time he starts
talking out of the other side of his
mouth and he says trump
is awful he's terrible he's practically
and morally responsible for what
happened i'm not going to hold him
accountable but
he's responsible but he goes on to say
you know it doesn't doesn't meet this
legal definition and so
he gets off the hook mcconnell he's this
great weathervane
i don't i'm not saying he's some kind of
liberal like a lincoln project
republican he's not
he's also not a trumpy republican he's
sticking his finger in the air and he's
saying which way is the wind blowing
how can i maintain my power how can i
exercise power today
well that's the question we're all
wondering which way is it going
some good news obviously trump gets
acquitted that's good he'll still exert
quite an influence in the party i think
that's a good thing his enemies
as as always seems to happen are
destroying themselves
this is i think drew clavin made this
point about trump
trump drives his enemies insane and then
causes them to destroy themselves and
this is what's happened with the lincoln
project
the lincoln project was always a
degenerate
uh con from the beginning i don't use
khan or grift or those kind of words
lightly but that's just what it is it
was these out of work
indebted dirtbag political consultants
who couldn't get a job in trump's
america working for republicans
so they switched teams they betrayed
their old
co-partisans they joined with the
democrats they milked these democrat
donors for all they were worth frankly
i thought it was great i'm glad the
lincoln project was squandering their
money
on private you know private expenses
so that that money wasn't going toward
actual good use during the campaign
but that's what they did they were
running ads on liberal tv shows in
liberal markets
no it wouldn't do anything to stop trump
but these guys i actually know some of
these guys personally so i'm speaking
with a little bit of authority here
they uh they wanted to make a quick buck
and and they did that now though there's
a big scandal because john weaver
who's a sort of legendarily disliked
uh political operative legendarily dirty
political operative
uh he was hitting on teenage boys and
it's very very sad for his family he's
married his kids and
secretly he was hitting on these teenage
boys and offering to give them political
jobs and help them in their careers
and the lincoln project didn't know
about this and
they're now pretending that they didn't
know about this but a lot of evidence
suggests they knew about it
steve schmidt who's another one of these
degenerates he also resigned from the
lincoln project he said oh no i never
knew about weaver or no i
i only learned about john weaver in
january and as the
journalist i think he's sort of a
left-wing journalist yashar ali pointed
out
steve schmidt doesn't uh clarify which
january he learned about it it was in
january of 2021 was a january
of 2010 january of 2005. and i don't
i don't think he's referring to this
january because these rumors about
weaver have been going on for a long
time but now like rats you know
fleeing the ship as it goes down all
these dirt bags are just completely
jumping off of the project
uh megan mccain just just really went
after the lincoln project it was
hilarious
because you know john weaver and some of
these other guys
worked for her dad worked for john
mccain and uh
john mccain was always a little bit more
of a liberal republican so he's kind of
being looped in with these guys
and megan comes and says don't you dare
loop me in with guys like john weaver
and the rest of them
she says quote i've been very hesitant
to comment but since my deceased father
keeps getting invoked i will say this
john weaver and steve schmidt were so
despised by my dad
he made it a point to ban them from his
funeral
since 2008 no mccain would have spit on
them
if they were on fire
but megan what do you really feel what
do you really think so i i was glad to
see that she made that point
because when people attack
guys like weaver or steve schmidt or the
lincoln project
if i were to attack them then you might
say well it's because you have this
ideological disagreement you're vying
for you know
different sections of the conservative
movement of the party but megan you know
is
certainly a little more to the center or
definitely to the left of me i mean
genghis khan is slightly to the left of
me but but megan certainly would be
and john mccain was would have been to
the left of me and even she's saying hey
these guys are unprincipled and so it's
it's really rich
when you hear from all of these sort of
persistent never trumpers like
the lincoln project or egg mcmuffin
whatever you know that that uh
spook who tried to beat donald trump as
running third party in
2016 didn't go very far
all these guys pretend that they're very
very principled
i don't find that to be the case they
say trump is vulgar and we need to
restore dignity
all these guys are way more vulgar than
donald trump and on top of that they're
deceitful at least with trump what you
see is what you get
with these guys they're holier than now
they're so sanctimonious
but point by point they're much worse
than trump
so so what does this mean in terms of
the way the left is going to view us
how can we move forward there is
there is no good reason
to follow the lincoln project strategy
of sucking up
to the left because
it doesn't it doesn't matter you know
there are i think i don't think it's all
cynical i don't think it's all just guys
like schmidt and weaver getting getting
rich
by you know convincing liberal donors to
give the money
i think some of them really believe it i
think i think there are people out there
who are
prob maybe some of the people who just
voted to convict donald trump in the
republican party
who think you know look i'm a
conservative but i'm not that kind of
conservative
if i just if i talk in a really mellow
but sort of condescending way and if i
say nice things about the libs and if i
say orange man bad
then the the left will respect me i'll
win the center
you know they and and we will all get
together in kumbaya and it's just
so stupid it's so wrong
the left makes no distinction
once they're useful idiots in the
lincoln project have done all they can
do what what happens that
falls apart okay they're cast aside they
make no distinction
between the trump supporting
conservatives and the more liberal
conservatives
you may have heard recently that uh
disney plus
has fired gina carano you've probably
heard it in this show today because i
already mentioned it
you you might have thought that the left
would succeed here
why did they fire her because she was
even vaguely conservative
then they made up some nonsense about
how she said something offensive she
didn't say anything even
remotely offensive so disney thought
they could kill her career we had
another thing in store for them
the minute disney tried to cancel gina
we called up gina we said hey you want
to work on something together
and we're going to fight back against
this canceled culture gina will be
developing producing and starring in an
upcoming film that will be
released exclusively to daily wire
members
we ain't going to take it anymore we're
not just going to criticize
what we call cancel culture we are
actually going to do something about it
now disney plus has an eight or nine
billion dollar annual budget planned
we have you i'm i'm pleased with our
position
in that uh split here okay i'd rather
have you that well eight or nine
it's a lot of money but i i really would
i'd rather have you you can really help
us though if you join today in the fight
to take back our culture
go to dailywire.com subscribe and use
code gina
g i n a you'll get 25 off your
membership today
dailywire.com subscribe code gina we'll
be right back with a lot more
joy reid who is some left-wing
commentator on
msnbc is
in the process not just of trying to
excise the trump faction from the
republican party and say look we need to
support the good republicans not the
trump ones
joy reid is delegitimizing the entire
gop
congressman schiff do we need to start
having a serious conversation
not just about donald trump being a bad
guy but about the republican party
becoming a radicalized anti-democratic
institution because
you can't have a regular party like the
democrats who have their flaws and we
can make ish have issue with them
and a party that is willing to seize
power by force because that's what that
sounded like to me
yeah you can't have a regular party
which totally respects democracy
and whose uh leading members uh
explicitly encourage political violence
and
who actually provide material support to
violent
radical left insurrectionists for months
and months from coast to coast
you know a normal good political party
can't coexist
with the party that where the guy with
the horns jumps on the capitol desk for
a few hours
you can't that the latter is completely
illegitimate and the former they're the
great defenders of democracy
they're they're such defenders of
democracy that if you don't support
democracy they're going to burn down
your business they're go oh yeah they're
going to set that government building on
fire
through mostly peaceful democratic
protests
you notice the left doesn't use the term
alt-right anymore
they used to use the term alt-right it
actually sort of had a meeting it was
kind of interesting
to debate what all these things meant
they don't use that anymore because they
don't it's not about the all right
oh there's the alt-right that's bad but
then there's the good conservatives and
we
like them no it's just all the same and
now increasingly they'll
they because donald trump supported the
nation state over
liberal imperialism globalism
globalization call it what you will
now they go after nationalism and they
try to say that all
nationalism is neo-nazism or white
supremacism so you'll hear they'll say
this is white
nationalism this is christian
nationalism
i think i'm not i'm not a christian
nationalist i'm a christian imperialist
that's that's a topic for another time
they think it's all the same we're all
nazis 75 million people are nazis in
this country and
adam schiff who joy reid is interviewing
backs her up
well no i think that's absolutely right
and you know i think the managers
they're talking about donald trump's
role because he's the one on trial and
that makes perfect sense
but the there are broader serious
problems with the gop
right now as a party it has really
become a cult of personality around the
president
it doesn't have an ideology anymore it
doesn't have principles
anymore and it's willing to welcome in
um white nationalists q anon conspiracy
theorists
people that will use violence if they
don't get their way
um and that party needs to to come to
grips
uh with what it's become um it needs to
be a party once again that stands for
something
and not just the the cult around donald
trump
so the republican party now welcomes in
racial identity politics conspiracy
theories and political violence
so what what schiff is objecting to is
that it's become the democratic party he
said oh man you know i preferred it when
those republicans
did not really resemble the democrats
quite so much this is really bad you
know what they need to do
they need to get back to having
principles now what what is schiff's
actual argument he's just kind of
spouting platitudes but
if he is making anything even resembling
an argument it's this
because so the republican party now
supports
identity politics conspiracy theories
and political violence
and therefore it's unprincipled
now you know i don't like racial
identity politics i don't like
conspiracy theories i don't like
political violence
but surely we have to admit those are
principles
the reason that i don't like them is
because i have different principles but
those are principles
the principles that i disagree with
now i don't the charges he's making
against the gop are ridiculous that he's
just projecting as the left often does
what does the gop support gop supports
national sovereignty uh love of country
strong social institutions the family
keeping your own property
uh recognizing a transcendent moral
order
you know you could go on and on what are
the what are the conservatives really
saying they have principles
what shift is upset about is they have
principles that the left disagrees with
and this broader left-wing project it's
sort of the topic of my
upcoming book speechless controlling
words controlling minds now available
for pre-order
it's got many more words than my first
magnum opus so you know it's a little
trickier to write but it's coming out
soon
the left through political correctness
woke-ism
you know whatever you want to call it
they are seeking this purely negative
campaign to
upend and destroy the old moral order
and practically what this does
is it replaces the old moral codes with
speech codes
and then and then what what shift is
saying is gop has no ideology
even though he's previously said they do
have this ideology that i don't like
then
he says they have no ideology it's
become a cult of personality
it hasn't become a cult of personality
there is just a person
who offered a different vision for the
gop this i felt ann coulter got this
so right about trump in 2016. the kind
of common consensus view
among all the typical establishment
people is that the reason
that republicans voted for trump is
despite his policies because
they loved his personality and i think
it's the opposite i agree with ann
coulter in her
wonderfully titled book e pluribus
awesome in trump we trust
you can always count on anne for a
really you know grab you kind of title
donald trump i think many people voted
for him in spite of his personality
i get a kick out of a lot of aspects of
his personality but there are things he
said and done well i think i don't
really like that i wish he wouldn't do
that
that
seems like he's shooting himself in the
foot i think a lot of people felt that
way but they thought you know
when i would go out and i talked to a
lot of people all around the country i'd
say
how do you think things are going this
was before kovit when you were still
allowed to travel
and very often people would say you know
he's the greatest president
he doesn't know how to shut up and he
can't take yes for an answer
and he says things that drive me crazy
but you know the guy is a really good
president
you had before trump you had a gop that
occasionally might pay lip service to
certain ideas
but basically they were for open borders
they're basically for amnesty
you know they all they really cared
about were sort of corporate tax cuts
they were
for total unfettered free trade meaning
prioritizing uh gdp as
one sort of arbitrary economic measure
over uh
workers right they'd say when you'd ask
them about outsourcing jobs they'd say
well it's inevitable i wish
i wish we could do something but it
would be wrong it would it would
somehow offend the free market peace be
upon her if we ever
you know suggested that we keep
manufacturing jobs in this country
then we couldn't get cheap chinese goods
and then jeff bezos
would be mad and so we can't you know we
can't do that at all
trump offered a different vision he
offered a vision that questioned the
inevitability of globalism
that fought strongly against globalism
he reoriented the republican party away
from this kind of thirst in howell iii
you know or the party of billionaires
which
we had been perceived as for a long time
toward a working-class party
and it was actually that shift toward
the working class that got trump in
trouble when he said look i love the
educated and i love the uneducated what
did the liberals do they made fun of him
donald trump loves the uneducated oh my
gosh
those idiots those rubes they didn't
even go to harvard
they don't even know that men can become
women those idiots don't even know that
babies aren't people
can you believe those stupid rubes and
as a result we got more working-class
people
and what did they call they called them
deplorable irredeemable bitter clingers
so in a way trump is sort of embodying
this shift
well he's a reference point for this
shift what's the future though
are we going back to the to the bush
days are we going back to the romney
days
or are we going in another direction
a direction that has great roots in the
american conservative tradition
but that had been lost for a number of
decades particularly
after the cold war now what i would like
to do ideally
is be able to go in just like the left
went in and infiltrated and subverted
our institutions
good conservative institutions i want to
be able to go in
to the liberal institutions and subvert
them from within
but my master plan to do this was foiled
over the weekend you know
some people have commented that no one
has ever seen me
and president biden's deputy press
secretary tj ducklow in the same place
at the same time it's an interesting
observation
uh unfortunately though tj
my doppelganger has been forced out of
the white house
because tj sounds like a little bit of a
dirt bag you know i mean basically
everybody in politics is
a little a little suspect they're not
all like the lincoln project but
everyone's a little uh you know these
are tough guys
and tj ducklow i got caught he was in
this relationship with a reporter and it
hadn't really been disclosed and they
tried to spin it into this wonderful
quirky love story but it's obviously
deeply unethical
and then when they were when they were
starting to write stories about this he
barely called up a reporter and said
horrifically offensive things to her
first he said i'm going to destroy you
i'll bury you you know but then he was
also saying sort of lurid sexual things
to her
and uh anyway this finally came out and
tj.lo said quote
no words can express my regret my
embarrassment and my disgust and my
behavior
i use language that no women should ever
have to hear from anyone
especially in a situation where she's
just trying to do her job it was
language that was abhorrent
disrespectful and unacceptable yeah not
fair enough i agree with that
and i don't even mention it to attack tj
ducklow i usually don't really go after
the staffers because i don't care you
know there are a lot of staffers
these guys are trying to you know make a
buck in politics have a career
control the world you know on honest
living by dc standards so i don't i
usually go after the principals i don't
go after the staffers
i only bring this up to remind you that
when you hear
in the coming days as you've heard from
the left from the
sort of liberal establishment as well as
from the liberal court jester
conservatives the fake
fake conservatives in the republican
party you're going to hear that trump is
uniquely
uh wicked undignified vulgar
upsetting of norms and it's just not
true it's just not true his opponents
are at least
as despicable as he is and and in many
cases
much more so so ducklow's out
my doppelganger's out i no longer will
have even a chance of affecting
a policy and divided administration and
the policy is clearly
shifting it's funny
joe biden refuses to acknowledge that
he's changing
u.s policy what he keeps going back to
is saying no i'm not
i'm not passing new laws i'm not issuing
new regulations i'm just going back to
normal
i'm just undoing all the stuff trump did
now if you have two brain cells to rub
together and any sort of objectivity
you'd look at that and say well hold on
the policy was this
for four years or however long and now
we have the policy is different so
you're
making new policy but the left can't
acknowledge that because
because what they're doing is right what
they're doing is normal what they're
doing is inevitable what they're doing
is the
the arc of history the science of
history progress
and there was this aberration for a
little while which was trump
and but now we're getting back on the
line of progress and many
many liberal republicans believe this
too
if you play for many liberal republicans
who pretend to love ronald reagan or
bill buckley or whoever
if you play for these liberal
republicans the actual words
of ronald reagan or bill buckley or
barry goldwater or frank meyer or
russell kirk or whoever
if you play the things they actually
believe not the not what the caricature
of these guys
is by today's standards not you know oh
ronald reagan
he would have loved transgender
bathrooms you know or whatever we hear
from these
ridiculous people but if you actually
hear what these guys said
the the liberal republicans would blanch
they would they would be shocked they
would be
they would they would disavow in in a
heartbeat
because what they would what they would
actually say i think is
yeah sure bill buckley defended
mccarthyism or something you know
whatever ronald reagan did this or that
ronald reagan defended the panama canal
who whatever
uh but that was just because it was a
product of their time
they were not as advanced if they were
alive today they would
have moderated their views and become
more liberal and what becomes clear
and you know i'm speaking anecdotally
but i think i'm i think i'm right about
this i think if you talk to enough of
these liberal switches that's what
they'll say
what becomes clear is they share the
left's view of history and politics
that you know things are basically
getting better and we shouldn't go
back to the past and yeah you know
some of the you know some of our
historical figures uh they said a lot of
horrible things that we hate but just
because they were in the past and the
presence better and the future's
going to be even better than that that
is just a different view of politics and
history than conservatives hold
in in a way it's this kind of bizarro
world version because
i guess you could say any christian has
a progressive view of history
right in the sense that
at the end of time christ is going to
come again and we're going to have a new
heaven and a new earth and
you know peaceful abound and rain right
but it's
but that progressive vision of history
is a little different because things are
going to get a lot worse before then
things are you know things started out
really well in the garden of eden and
then they got like pretty
pretty bad and then the world that god
had destroyed the world in a flood you
know and then things are but they're
getting kind of bad again and
even at a simpler level than that
the conservative view of history is it
you know sometimes things get better
sometimes things get worse
and right now we
i think we need to obviously stop
listening to these liberal republicans
but start thinking of politics
differently not just on this line of
progress
with a capital p not just forward or
backward but just
actually talking about what is good what
is enduring what is true what is
good what do we believe today tomorrow
and the next day
what are those principles that we stand
for
the only the only unprincipled people i
see are these liberal squishy republi
you know guys like the lincoln project
or
them they they have uh
mistaken you know i mean they're they're
deceivers
and then the actual true believing
liberals and the republican and
democratic party they've got mistaken
principles
this faith and you know progress we need
to know what
do we stand for
a good piece of evidence that the biden
administration is changing u.s policy
is with regard to one of our allies
israel you know that israel had a great
relationship with the united states
under the trump administration
it's funny because they would call trump
literally hitler
you know i'd say he was an anti-semite
worst anti-semite in history
least successful anti-zemite they named
a town for him in israel
can you imagine wow gosh what a what an
ineffective anti-semite
because son-in-law is an orthodox jew
right it's not very effective
so israel has a great relationship under
trump
now the question is what's that
relationship going to be like joe biden
has had a pretty good relationship with
israel back when democrats were more
moderate
but obviously joe biden is not the man
he once was
in terms of his policy views i actually
think he is the same man i think
he's not principled he licks his finger
puts it in the air figures out which way
the wind is blowing and that's what he
believes he's a total empty suit he's
just a glad handing
a typical politician if you weren't a
politician he'd be selling used cars
and the party has moved very far to the
left so therefore
the administration would appear to be
moving that way too listen to jen saki
explain the administration's view on
israel
can you please just give us a broad
sense of what the administration is
trying to achieve in the middle east
for example does the administration
still consider the the saudis and the
israelis important allies
uh well uh you know again i think we
uh there are ongoing processes and
internal interagency processes one that
we i think confirmed an interagency
meeting just last week to discuss
a range of issues in the middle east um
where we've only been here three and a
half weeks
and i think i'm gonna let those policy
processes see themselves through before
we give kind of a
complete lay down of what our national
security approaches will be to a range
of issues
this woman is so bad at her job it's
just she
i get that part of her job is dodging
questions so i'm not knocking her for
that but she's just
she's just bad at ducking questions like
she does
ah man tj ducklow if he weren't if he
weren't such a derelict on those phone
calls he really
would have had a great opportunity here
so
question you know are you going to keep
up these policies with israel don't
forget
we were told by john kerry who's in the
biden administration by other prominent
democrats
you'll never get any peace with israel
and other muslim nations
if you don't first deal with the
palestinian question it can't happen
you know john kerry thurston hello iii
said this
verbatim and then what does trump do
he ignores the palestinian question he
just starts dealing with these
individual nations
he signs record peace deals with israel
and a lot of muslim nations
so you know is biden going to keep this
up obviously biden's not going to keep
this up because the way that
that the trump administration secured
these kind of deals was in large part
leaning on saudi arabia against iran
ripping up the iran nuclear deal and
that sort of thing
right and by working with saudi arabia
they were able to secure a lot of these
deals
but the biden administration and the
democrats
don't like saudi arabia they like iran
right you kind of got to pick a side
when you're talking about saudi and iran
the democrats think that their path to
success is to suck up to iran
so obviously they're not going to pursue
the same policy with regard to israel or
the middle east
and gensock he can't say that yet but
that's you know that's going to be a
fundamental reordering of american
policy to the middle east
this is going to be true in china this
is going to be true
all over the world this is going to be
true with our policies in europe even
and with russia is
you're going to have an upending of this
foreign policy it's too bad because
trump
especially as a foreign policy president
is far and away the the best of my
lifetime probably the
certainly the best since reagan and who
you know maybe even uh
maybe he rivals reagan too maybe goes
back even further
but on the domestic front joe biden just
announced he's going to end
the border wall construction this was
the central trump campaign promise
basically right we're going to build a
big beautiful wall mexico is going to
pay for it
and he was held up a lot of steps of the
way i think he was trying they did build
some wall they didn't build a ton of
wall but they did build some
they fixed old wall and biden has come
in and said nope that's over now
that's completely over and
what we're being told from the liberals
is that this is in defense of the open
society
right the open society that uh
conservatives once used to openly
deplore but now they
they sort of pretend to like because
we've been duped by the left and we use
all their own language
we say well we're free speech purists we
want total open marketplace of ideas no
boundaries whatsoever
this is i know i know a lot of
conservatives say this today but
that's we've we've taken the bait from
the left in the last 20 years guys like
bill buckley ronald reagan they would
not have said this they and
explicitly argued against it actually
because this isn't an open society
this is not an open society joe biden is
not pushing an open society
it's an open society to illegal aliens
the society they're pushing is open to
hostile foreign nations
like china and other places
to places where travel was banned
because it was
they could not secure it now travel's
going to be open to them that's open to
them
but it isn't open to us because while
joe biden is
effectively opening our southern border
he is threatening
to close the border with florida
mexico totally fine no wall no border
florida they're probably going to build
a big beautiful wall around florida by
the time joe biden is done jinsaki
was asked about this because it is being
seriously floated now
that the united states at the federal
level could halt
travel to and from florida the miami
herald reported yesterday that the biden
administration is considering
travel restrictions on states like
florida to help stop the spread of the
coronavirus can you
rule that out or is that off as they say
on the table
well i've seen those reports we are
always considering what steps are
necessary to keep the american people
safe but we are not currently
in the process of no decisions have been
made around additional public health
measures that would
delay or would change i should say
domestic travel
considerations joe biden should have
used zip recruiter unfortunately for him
he did not and this woman was not very
persuasive
she doesn't want to come out right in
front and say yeah we're going to cut
off travel from florida we're going to
prevent federal employees from
however they're going to do it but she
doesn't say no it's a ridiculous it's an
absolutely preposterous idea florida has
done so
much better on coronavirus than new york
than uh california than
many other places in chicago many other
places in the country
but all those cities and states are run
by liberals
so that's totally fine totally open ron
desantis the republican
is running florida florida's done a
great job so now we've got to talk about
the cases skyrocketing and whatever
we've got to cut it off desantis came
out obviously and
pushed back against this pretty hard
it's a it's a reordering of the country
which way are we going to go are we
going to
knock down our national borders and
build up borders within ourselves
are we going to try to win the applause
of the left
and you know vote against trump or sort
of principled conservatives
no so much of the way that the left has
advanced over the last
40 60 even 100 years is by manipulating
language
all of these sorts of things we hear
principles
the people who invoke principles all the
time the least principled people i know
trump is impeached donald trump is the
most
innocent president we've ever had just
as just by the number of acquittals
two acquittals no one's ever beaten that
another record chalk it up for trump
this question of open society borders
locking down unity and healing
if it wasn't clear before i hope it's
clear now
that the democratic party that the white
house is actually entertaining the idea
of
cutting off a u.s state the unity in
healing is not going to happen
and these rats who like the lincoln
project
want to run away from the people who are
actually on their side
defending principles that they at least
once had or ought to have
if these rats think that they're going
to be welcomed by the
democrats or by the liberal
establishment they've got another thing
coming
it's just not going to work for them the
trial
is not over the the impeachment force is
over the real trial is about to begin
where do you stand
that's our show i'm michael knows this
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadovsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 on the matt wall show we talk about
the things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show